Світ готується до економічної кризи.
Через поширення коронавірусу зупиняють заводи і фабрики,
скасовують авіарейси та масові заходи.
Як це може вплинути на українську економіку,
а саме як епідемія позначиться на житті пересічних українців?
Лише минулого року, за даними НБУ, в Україну надійшло грошових переказів
на 5 з половиною мільярдів доларів з різних країн, переважно з Євросоюзу.
На тлі паніки довкола коронавірусу українські заробітчани, передусім з Італії,
починають масово повертатися додому.
Крім того, через рецесію, яку прогнозують через коронавірус,
українські заробітчани в ЄС можуть одними з перших потрапити під скорочення.
Відповідно значно поменшає валютних надходжень,
які підтримували українську економіку, вважають експерти.
Ні тлі світової кризи скорочення робочих місць буде і в Україні.
Компаніям, насамперед тим, що працюють з міжнародними партнерами,
зокрема китайськими, доведеться боротися з новими викликами
і, ймовірно, урізати штат співробітників або їхні зарплати.
Також від карантину потерпатимуть заклади громадського харчування,
готельний, туристичний бізнес-
За різними оцінками, скорочення може бути до 30 відсотків.
Падіння продажів, обсягів виробництваі загалом ділової активності
неминуче, кажуть економісти.
Питання лише наскільки масштабним воно буде -
нині це передбачити складно.
Все залежить від темпів поширення коронавірусу
та рівня паніки в суспільстві.
У деяких українських містах вже масово скуповують товари першої необхідності.
Через штучний ажіотаж створюються проблеми в галузі постачання-
В Україні туризм, на відміну від Італії чи Іспанії,
далеко не першорядна галузь бюджетних надходжень.
За даними колишнього міністра економіки Милованова,
зовнішній туризм в Україні становить лише 2% ВВП.
Тим не менше це негативно позначиться на малому і середньому бізнесі.
Готелі, кафе і ресторани, розважальні центри, перевізники і не лише авіаційні -
усі вони, швидше за все, зазнаватимуть збитків,
що вплине на рівень життя людей, задіяних у цій галузі.
Китай - один з найбільших виробників і постачальників
різноманітних товарів від одягу до високотехнологічної техніки і комплектуючих.
Через коронавірус Піднебесна, по суті,
опинилася в економічній блокаді.
Ланцюжок поставки продукції по всьому світу порушився.
Україна не є глобальним гравцем,
але це все одно позначиться на багатьох українських фірмах,
пов’язаних з закупівлею товарів у Китаї.
Деякі компанії можуть збанкротувати, попереджають експерти.
Водночас, український прем’єр Денис ШмигАль запевняє,
що Україна входить у світову фінансово-економічну кризу набагато міцнішою,
ніж це було під час кризи 2008-го року.
Крім того, за його словами,
можуть відкритися нові можливості
для українських виробників.
Паніка на світових фінансових ринках через коронавірус,
обвал цін на нафту, зміну уряду в Україні та інші фактори -
все це не сприяє стабільності курсу гривні.
Спекулянти гратимуть на емоціях і реальних кризах,
тож коливання гривні триватиме, але різкого обвалу
бути не повинно, зазначають оглядачі.
Адже Нацбанк встиг накопичити великі золотовалютні резерви
і готовий стримувати валютні стрибки.
Втім, наскільки вистачить цієї підтримки в умовах глобальної економічної кризи,
прогнозувати ніхто не береться.
Багато чого буде залежати від співпраці з МВФ.
Тим більше, що цей рік для України є піковим
для виплати багатомільярдних боргів
а перспективи залучення іноземного капіталу будуть лише зменшуватися.
І це не абстрактні тренди в макроекономіці, зазначають експерти,
а реальні фактори, які вплинуть на гаманці пересічних українців.